scary as that is I'm smiling because is
that is that the trail that got shown in
a cinema in Australia it was not that
one it is very similar there there is a
story about a bunch of parents who took
their kids to see Peter Rabbit in
Western Australia I screams they start
to play the trailers and lo and behold
that comes off this screaming tune on
projection is because that doesn't
happen anymore stuck covering their kids
ears and eyes and it is appalling what a
[ __ ] who would do just shot Peter
Rabbit in front of them and people
people say actors talk about even when
they do spooky films like this that
often weird things happen so did that
happen on this not on this one but I
mean I have experienced something like
that before
almost I do this one call the sixth
sense and yeah I kind of it was the
first time I got into yoga I was
meditating a lot and this Venus kept
happening night after night I would wake
up and the clock would say eleven eleven
or one one one it's the same thing you
do yeah it feels I mean how do you
interpret it just get a new battery for
this so often more so than I mean more
than anything else but I mean more than
any other number I mean citizen all one
one one team branched out into 333 for
me I always interpret it as like somehow
I'm on the right track or you know some
units yeah I don't know it's a mystery I
don't understand it but it feels somehow
I think there's some sort of weird
unconscious thing going on in your head
cuz I can do a thing where I say to
myself I've got to wake up at 6:30
anyway have it at 6:30 - right so I
think your brain is actually much
cleverer than you
you know they realize yeah absolutely
but Joe and you have dabbled in the dark
arts have you know I have
yeah you did Brad you tell you did not I
did I'm too scared to do that oh it's
great we were obviously and without any
prompting at all this class that we all
had our fingers on spelt out knowledge
is not free right none of us were
intelligent enough to have come up with
that phrase ask it you know so we asked
what prices knowledge and it spelt out
your life and the glass shot off the
table I literally just got goose bones
oh no I've never done it because because
you've done it haven't you yeah yeah my
you're giving some power to this and I'm
liking that because my sister and I were
doing the Ouija board once us about 12
and my sister asked Luigi board who I
was in my past life I was on the board I
mean technically my fingers were
touching it and it spelled out James
Dean
[Applause]
no real man so one Ian Dean
[Music]
you